I got the new Bond theme very exciting  grammy-winning artist Billy Eilish sings  the newest James Bond theme song for the  upcoming movie no time to die the song  by that has the same title it was added  to the movie trailer  take a listen  [Music]  at 18 Eilish is the youngest person to  write and record a bond theme song which  he wrote with her brother last month of  course she won five Grammy Awards so  this is the first new music she's had  since then she will perform it live for  the first time next week at the BRIT  Awards which of course are the British  grandmas sounds terrific I mean it makes  the whole movie seem like a music video  for her there's actually it's I think  everybody has a favorite Bond theme you  guys have one I can't say I don't you  can't say you do okay I don't know that  I can name one off the top of my head  Goldfinger is my favorite Shirley Bassey  who is actually the only person who's  done more than one Bond theme she's done  three actually very good